[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi est dit
mais les collèges yvelinois en pleine
rénovation le président du conseil
départemental pierre bédier était en
déplacement aujourd'hui dans un
établissement à magny les hameaux pour
présenter les travaux prévus dans une
vingtaine de collèges du département et
des travaux qui doivent permettre de
pallier aux différents
dysfonctionnements la coupe de france de
l'américaine également dans l'actualité
et c'est du cyclisme sur piste la
compétition se déroulait cet après midi
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les détails à
suivre sur cette épreuve méconnu mais
néanmoins impressionnante des paysages
époustouflants une vue unique et des
sensations hors du commun c'est ce que
ressentent les pilotes de montagne et
c'était aussi l'objet d'une conférence
il ya quelques jours à villepreux le
collège albert einstein de
magny-les-hameaux bientôt restructurer
une première pour ce bâtiment depuis les
années 70 il s'agit d'une demande de la
part des enseignants mais aussi des
parents d'élèves qui pointé plusieurs
dysfonctionnements dans l'établissement
pierre bédier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines étaient sur
place ce matin pour parler justement de
ces travaux ils seront menées par le
département un reportage de camille
lambert des salles trop petites
une peinture vieillissante et une
connexion limitée voilà quelques-uns des
problèmes du collège albert einstein
l'équipe éducative et parents d'élèves
ont alerté sur la dégradation du
bâtiment lors d'un conseil
d'administration
alexandra rosetti conseillère
départementale a porté la voix auprès du
président des yvelines
on voit bien que en termes de sécurité
c'est pas du tout optimum
vu la taille des salles vu le manque de
sorties de secours en terme
d'électricité en termes de réseau de
tout le monde c'est vrai commencé à
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
donc
je pense que c'était
bien qu'on puisse réagir et je suis ravi
que le président est soit venu visiter
de lui-même là pour constater
qu'effectivement ce n'était pas exagéré
le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier a donc visité le bâtiment
d'une quarantaine d'années construit
pour accueillir initialement 600 élèves
il ne peut en recevoir plus de 475 la
rénovation sera totalement prise en
charge par le département
coût total des travaux plus de 6
millions d'euros
on va faire les espaces extérieurs
agrandir le parking des profs refaire
une
une cour je pense qu'on peut dire de
récréation au collège
ensuite nous allons restructurer un
restructurer les salles de classe
lorsqu'elles sont trop petites
refaire a naturellement tous les
couloirs les revêtements une
restructuration qui s'intègre dans un
projet plus large le département prévoit
de rénover 20 établissements d'ici 2021
à magny les hameaux
les travaux débuteront dès cet été aux
politiques et la bataille des élections
législatives est lancée alors que les
grands partis n'ont pas encore dévoilé
le nom de leur candidat les petites
formations elles s'organisent c'est le
cas du mouvement 577 les indépendants de
la droite et du centre un mouvement
lancé par le maire de neuilly-sur-seine
jean-christophe fromantin qui était
d'ailleurs présent vous le voyez il ya
quelques jours à versailles pour
soutenir le candidat investi sur la
première circonscription des yvelines
est nicolas jacquot karmique et al un
entrepreneur de 46 ans basé à montigny
le bretonneux et qui souhaite réinventer
notamment la relation entre élus et
électeurs
écoutez le ça passe par une permanence
parlementaire ouverte
ça passe par un accès facilité à son
député ça passe par l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux et des moyens modernes
de communication qui permettent de
consulter rapidement les citoyens
d'avoir des retours d'expérience ou des
informations sur le bien fondé d'une
mesure qui serait à prendre et ça évite
de prendre des lois qui ne sont soit 1
applicables soient déconnectés de la
réalité des citoyens
on connaît désormais le visage de
l'homme recherché par la police dans les
yvelines depuis plusieurs jours pour
différentes fusillade attrapé à plaisir
bilan depuis samedi soir deux blessés et
un mort l'homme activement recherché de
33 ans est connu des services de police
pour des faits de violence antérieurs la
piste d'une vengeance personnelle est
désormais privilégiée le parquet de
versailles a ouvert deux informations
judiciaires l'une pour assassinat
l'autre pour tentative d'assassinât
dans le reste de l'actualité locale du
sport et la coupe de france de
l'américaine qui se tenait cet après
midi au vélodrome nationale 2 à saint
quentin en yvelines une épreuve de
cyclisme sur piste que l'on peut
comparer à un relais en tandem plus de
140 participants répartis dans cinq
catégories étaient présents pour cette
compétition les détails avec michael et
demi d'euros ce mercredi 10 mai lever le
double national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli
l'une des compétitions les plus
spectaculaires du cyclisme sur piste la
course à l'américaine alors l'américaine
c'est une épreuve par équipes de deux
coureurs
sachant que c'est une épreuve de run et
dom cole et power pendant 2 ou 3
toujours ça là ça dépend l allure où ça
roule et passe le relais à leurs
collègues
et puis tous les plusieurs dizaines de
tours y allait y aller classement où les
gens ont doivent prendre des points pour
cette seconde coupe de france organisée
dans la structure 70 équipes issues de
13 comités régionaux se sont inscrits
essayez de faire voir ce qu'on peut ce
qu'on peut donner serait triste savoir
si on peut surprendre dans une catégorie
ou dans deux clubs
c'est important d'être ici parce que
l'on montre un peu bon déjà les couleurs
de l'auvergne ronald la maîtrise y
rouler sur un aussi beau vélodrome
comme je suis quand même très content
d'y être
sur la piste les cours n'ont pas hésité
à jouer des coudes pour remporter la
victoire au péril de leur sécurité
il n'ya pas toujours la place pour tout
le monde et des fois il ya des coureurs
qui veulent passer en dessous alors que
par par code on doit passer au dessus
donc voilà ça frotte notamment chez les
jeux ne sont pas encore très très
habitué la difficulté d'américaines
c'est qu'il faut voir loin et c'est
compliqué de voir loin devant vous la
vie les coureurs qui ont réussi à tenir
sur leurs vélos en réalisant les
meilleurs chronos seront qualifiés pour
les futurs championnats de france 2010
est la compétition se déroulera cet été
à saint cyr l'école la commune célèbre
cette semaine l'europe avec une
exposition qui a lieu jusqu'au 13 mai en
mairie sur la réconciliation franco
allemande
une vingtaine de panneaux sont à
découvrir autour du rôle des deux hommes
politiques emblématiques de l'époque le
général de gaulle et le chancelier
adenauer reportage de stéphane servant
des textes en français et en allemand
des photos pour raconter l'histoire
tourmentée des relations entre les deux
pays
l'exposition présentée actuellement à
saint-cyr-l'ecole revient sur la volonté
de deux hommes le général de gaulle et
le chancelier konrad adenauer d'établir
enfin une paix durable
vingt ans après la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est à partir de la
réconciliation entre ces deux nations
qui se sont déchirées que tous les
autres peuples européens pouvaient se
réconcilier et former une unité
européenne
l'exposition détaille les nombreux
voyages des deux hommes en allemagne et
en france jusqu'à la signature du traité
de l'elysée le 22 janvier 1963 qui
consacre le rapprochement des deux pays
une étape importante de la construction
de l'europe le président elysées il
transforme
en actes juridiques il concrétise la
collaboration désormais entre les les
deux pays le rapprochement avec des
éléments très concrets dans le domaine
politique dans le domaine économique
dans le domaine culturel
alors que la ville va fêter l'année
prochaine les dix ans de son jumelage
avec la ville de bourges stats
cette exposition permet également au
grand public de comprendre de
l'importance des échanges entre les deux
pays
il était important aussi que lorsque
l'on voit que certains remettent
l'europe en cause de rappeler que c'est
l'amitié entre la france et l'allemagne
qui est le ciment fondateurs de l'europe
samedi 13 mai une conférence aura lieu à
l'hôtel de ville avec le président des
amis de la fondation charles de gaulle
c'est un rêve pour beaucoup de pilotes
et que peu de personnes peuvent se
vanter de connaître voler en montagne à
travers les glaciers en plein coeur des
massifs
c'est aussi l'objet d'une conférence
était aussi l'objet d'une conférence
excusez-moi la médiathèque de villes pro
il ya quelques jours un voyage en
altitude pour s'émerveiller yves hub
stand berger ce sont des prises de vue
d'une beauté exceptionnelle
hiver comme été voici à quoi ressemble
les parois du massif du mont blanc
un privilège pour les pilotes qui vole
en montagne et ce jour-là à villepreux
ils sont deux à partager leurs
expériences avec l'assistance
l'occasion de rappeler notamment
l'hostilité des montagnes une fois la
tête dans les nuages ne serait-ce que la
proximité de la paroisse
l'altitude à laquelle vol l'avion le
le manque d'oxygène aux 6e et puis les
instabilités verticale qui peuvent
quelquefois dans certaines situations
s'avérer dangereuse donc ça nécessite
des précautions avant de rentrer dans
les dents dans les vallées glaciaires à
villepreux cette conférence organisée
par l'association audace s'inscrit dans
une programmation plus large autour de
l'aviation avec notamment une exposition
photo à la mairie à la médiathèque
jusqu'au 24 mai prochain ça permet donc
à la fois d'être dans le culturel au
sens de la culture scientifique mais
aussi d'être dans une continuer scié par
continuité par rapport à l'enseignement
à la pédagogie
donc on rentre on voit comment avec des
projets comme ça on rentre complètement
dans une boucle qui est informative
plaisir mais aussi qui est sur quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre de
l'enseignement de l'information pour les
jeunes et ça c'est très important pour
nous la médiathèque de villepreux
accueillera une nouvelle conférence en
octobre prochain autour du tourisme
spatial une conférence qui s'inscrira
cette fois ci dans le programme de la
semaine de la science
voilà une première que les jeunes
padawan attendent sûrement avec
impatience l'académie du sabre laser
basée à voisins le bretonneux organise
dimanche son premier championnat
interclubs
mais alors en quoi consiste cette
pratique est ce vraiment un sport est ce
dangereux la rédaction de tv fil 78
répondait déjà à toutes ces questions
dans un reportage diffusé il ya quelques
mois regardez
[Musique]
j'ai été formé à une seule chose
je n'ai aucune cause à défendre pour
devenir un jedi vous n'avez pas besoin
de partir dans une galaxie lointaine
très lointaine les maîtres de l'académie
du sabre laser ont organisé un stage
pour apprendre le maniement de cette
arme à voisins bretons ne les fondateurs
sont formels la discipline originaires
des etats unis un sport de combat à part
entière la pratique du sabre laser quand
elle a été codifié dans les films star
wars était surtout inspiré du kendo
également aussi un petit peu des scream
française et de la canne de combat donc
ces univers sportif et martial font
qu'il ya une codification qui s'est
effectuée au niveau des frappes des
parades des zones de touche est
effectivement en fait l'esprit du sabre
il est vraiment présent tout le temps
avec la pratique du sabre laser pour
pratiquer ce sport plusieurs éléments
sont nécessaires avant de se lancer dans
les duels
un casque un plastron et des gants de
protection sont obligatoires le sabre
laser et lui fabriqué en polycarbonate
et si les mines avec un système de led
c'est pas un jouet c'est une vraie arme
entre guillemets c'est à dire que c'est
quelque chose assez dur qui peut
s'entrechoquer comme c'est pour ça tu
peux faire de la compétition des duels
ce stage organisé pour la première fois
dans le département des yvelines a réuni
une vingtaine de padawan ces visuels
c'est
convivial donc c'est intéressant c'est
agréable après c'est du sport aussi quoi
donc
et s'y attendait un peu moins à 9 heures
du matin av mais bon ça fait plaisir
très bon construit ça a l'air très pro
otan dans les techniques tant dans
l'enseignement etc
il ya des vins technique donc quand on
est une star wars et puis quand on veut
faire du sport à 120 l'aspect très
ludique et très amusant parce que du
coup on met un pied dans l'univers entre
ce sport compte déjà plus de dix clubs
en france et 350 pratiquants réguliers
dans l'hexagone une fédération française
a également vu le jour en 2015
après quelques séances d'entraînement
ces apprentis de viendront sans doute
les prochains luke skywalker
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay sur tv fil 78
points comme ou l'application tv fil 78
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]